[Caroline] For the past two years,
I've had the opportunity
to travel with my friends
to amazing destinations.
While we can't travel this year,
I am virtually meeting
up with them to share
our favorite travel memories,
and where we're looking
forward to heading next.
Oh my gosh, I missed you guys.
My friends and I have experienced
life-changing adventures
across the US and Europe, empowered by
my Marriott Bonvoy Boundless™ Card.
Earlier this year, we began planning for
"Travel Dares Season 3,"
but as you can expect
our travels were put on hold.
If you're watching this video,
you probably had to cancel
a trip or two yourself.
So, why not let our
adventures on "Travel Dares"
inspire your future trip planning?
[Joe] I know what my favorite one was.
It was the extreme tubing
we did in Salt Lake City.
The view going down that
hill on that inner tube
was amazing, it was such a rush.
I was talking about that
weeks after that trip.
It was just such a rush,
and it was so much fun.
[Nico] I have to say it was the
suspension bridge in France.
The feeling of even getting up there,
we were just like, 'Oh my God,
we're going higher and higher'
what's going to happen?
And then we get there
and the bridge is like this wide.
And we're like, we're gonna get on that?
Definitely that was like
something I would never do
on my own, but for this
show, I was like, 'OK,
we're doing it,' and I'm glad I did.
No one can ever say
anything to me ever again.
I am the bravest woman alive,
and I don't care what you say.
[Aj] Alright, so my favorite dare was
definitely the water slide in Austria.
I don't know why, but
there's just something
about being thrown 25 feet
in the air, like a rag doll,
that I just really love.
I wanna go back, and do it again so bad.
[Caroline] Maybe I would have
to say when Joe dared me
to go in the individual
submarines in The Bahamas.
I love the water, and we got
to be so close to marine life,
and it's a very safe way
for us and the environment.
And it was just so nice
to just be in the ocean
and feel the water and everything.
[Joe] I have to know. I saw
the video, but from you guys,
I wanna ask you, what was it
like being into quicksand?
[Aj] I don't know, it's
kinda hard to describe.
You don't feel it when you're in there.
But once you try to move,
that's when it actually pulls on you.
[Caroline] The way it feels,
it's almost like you're glued
and cemented into the ground,
until you start doing the technique of
kind of wiggling your leg.
It's kind of a strange
feeling, but once you're free,
you can move and wiggle your legs again,
which is the first thing I did.
[Joe] The Bahamas.
I had never been to any
sort of tropical island
or tropical destination in my
life - this was my first time.
And everything about
that trip was amazing.
The second I stepped off the
plane, I was just like,'wow!'
I mean, I loved the
food, I loved the people,
I loved how everything
looked, I loved the beach.
I loved the hotel we stayed
at, The Coral At Atlantis.
Everything about that from start
to finish, I was just like,
'yes, I understand why
people vacation here.'
[Aj] For me, it was definitely Naples.
Mostly because it's a coastal city,
there's water everywhere.
We were taking boats to places
and I really loved that.
Everything about Naples
was what I want
in a vacation spot.
[Nico] Every time people ask
me what my favorite place was,
I say Switzerland.
Because I've never breathed
as fresh air as I did there .
It was so weird, I was like,
why does everything feel so good here?
Everything's just so beautiful,
natural, skies were blue.
It was perfect, out of a storybook.
Aside from learning, how
popular and delicious
the khachapuri was, I think
the fact that there are
40 variations of it was
kind of mind blowing.
And now I guess we have
to go back to Georgia
and try the others.
Oh my God that is so good.
[Caroline] For me, when we
went to Wales, and we went on
the Pontcysyllte Aqueduct,
it was really cool
because it not only was
a stunning structure
and a world heritage site,
but it was something that was built,
in the early 1800s
So the engineering, is just incredible.
[Nico] The Renaissance
Aix-en-Provence was probably
the coolest hotel I had ever seen.
There was this one room we
went to, and it had all of this
really, really cool local art,
and some of it was interactive.
I had never seen anything like it.
[Joe] I'm going to be
going to Rome, Italy.
My wife has never been to
Italy, and I used to live there.
So, we are still planning to go there,
the first chance we get.
[Aj] So, Paris is on the
list as the next trip now.
So going back to Paris, and
I'm actually really excited
about that because I had
a great time in Paris.
[Nico] So I'm actually half Dominican,
and I've never been to
the Dominican Republic.
It's always been one of those places that,
I really wanted to go.
It's white sand beaches,
crystal-clear blue water.
It's gorgeous. There's so much greenery.
And I'm gonna get to
meet a bunch of family
that I've never met
before in my entire life.
So, I feel like something
like that would be
a dream vacation once I
can do it. Hopefully soon.
[Caroline] So the first
place I'd love to travel to,
when we're able to do so is,
I want to go back to Armenia
with my family because I'm
Armenian and I went there
last year for a short
period of time for work.
And, it was amazing
because I was able to meet
so many family members
I've never met before,
and just learn about the
country's history and heritage.
I also want to take my mom back to Armenia
and have her see it after so
many years of not being there,
and just see how the
country's changed and stuff.
So, I'm trying to save up a lot of points
to make that trip happen for us.
[Aj] I've never traveled
abroad until Travel Dares.
So this is my first experience,
leaving the country.
You really see how big the world is,
and how much there is to experience.
I just see the world just
completely different now.
And I'm just so grateful to
have had that opportunity.
[Joe] Thanks to Travel
Dares, I got to travel to
parts of this country
that I probably don't know
if I would have ever gone before,
especially Salt Lake City.
I was like, 'whoa, this city
rules.' Utah is incredible.
And Santa Fe, New Mexico
is another place that
just never was really on my radar.
The show really gave me an opportunity,
to see parts of this country
that I hadn't seen before.
And I'm very glad that I did because now
I really want to explore
more of the United States.
[Nico] For me, I've kind of
always been a little bit scared,
of the unexpected, of the new.
But, this whole experience has
completely changed my mind.
Now I want more of the new.
I want more of the things
that I've never done before,
never seen before, never eaten before.
And now I feel like I'm
welcoming the new experiences,
instead of being scared of them.
[Caroline] I can't wait to
travel with you all so soon.
Where are we going to go?
We should plan it now.
[Nico] That's what we have
to start thinking about.
Where are we going next,
on our next adventure?
[Caroline] And we hope our past adventures
inspire you to make
future trip plans, too.
So that you're ready to go when
we're able to explore again.